people will go crazy ten good-looking
men on one song can't go wrong we're not
we're not complaining
[Applause]
[Music]
what's that bTW we are CEO hide CEO it's
pretty much oh we're here backstage and
our set of ministry that were pretty
much and we're on set Yahoo our new
music video - eita featuring cnc oh so
don't miss this is gonna be fine so come
check this oh oh
[Music]
hi CNC oh thank you so much for inviting
ET on the set of your new music video
for men as Aziza how excited are you to
be here today super excited is the first
time that we curl up with a boy band
actually I think it's the first time
that any boy band
pallab in history so we can say that we
make any it's been cool just like you
know guys dance and they dance - we
dance oh it was kind of cool to like
just dance around with each other and
bounce off ideas with each other so it's
been a really good time she come back it
is hot in here work sweat talk to me
about this music video and what we're
gonna see doing in these outfits we're
just going around with the guys and
we're gonna play be playing a little
game of football soccer soccer game
we're going to do a little choreo we're
really excited for it to see a lot of
high action soccer higher action than
you would think flying I'm out of
flipping he stops a ball with his bare
hands and it's super fast yeah a lot of
fireball fireball so you're gonna see a
lot of cool stunts but you're also gonna
see we really really really dope dancing
like you said tango looking dudes we
just dressed flies huh
we gotta talk about the stunt you guys
apparently sent the stunt double home
and decided to do it all yourselves the
stunt double was actually spider-man
like he's basically spider-man because
he does the the stunts for spider-man we
had so much fun because it's alway
cables we had to like pretend like
you're flying and it just felt like a
cool experience that we've never done
before we are there our stunts we all
did our tricks so it just felt like like
this is gonna be a very epic video we
got to do our own stunts so that was a
person we worked with the same guy who
just did some man worked for spider-man
I was going crazy it was like hot I
would look at him out here I think I was
flipping in there yeah he was flipping
he was doing kicks I was head-butting
stuff he was doing all I mean very high
tension you had to really train actually
though I'm like bruised all the way I
was like hanging up in the air and I had
to like anybody else boys
[Music]
one of the things that I think is so
incredible about CNC oh and pretty much
you guys really prioritize dancing and
you guys just bring it every single time
talk to me about how much practice goes
into learning the choreography for a
video like this we've put in a lot of
hard work into everything that we do we
enjoy it a lot especially this time
because it's a different style a
different type of dance a different type
of float so being able to work with
other choreographers like in you it was
super cool we learn new stuff and we
just you know we're happy that we're
getting to live this experience we're
doing dancing that pertains to them but
then they're also doing dancing that
pertains to us in terms of just like
different dance styles a lot of times we
get a little bit more intricate when it
comes to like our dancing but for them
they like to tend to group with their
dancing because I just how the culture
is the dance culture is out there so it
was cool cuz we got to be challenged and
they got to be challenged as well she
she come back you've learned from them
that you really admire something that
they do that you guys just think it's so
cool
their whole get in life that's how they
got it super different
so it's like it's two words I can't
really do it like that but you know it's
two words
combining you know so it's super cool to
see how different but the same we are
you know men do to inspire to favorite
song I really like the one that goes
high because they actually like each
other and they dance and they can speak
amazing Spanish singing in Spanish
amazingly you know they're super cool
they're just real real dudes every like
we used to just hang out every time like
we like ran into each other and now yeah
now we're tight what do you hope people
feel when they hear the song for the
first time and watch the video I hope
they go crazy that's the reaction we
kind of want they want a new Spider Man
you know there's five of us here
you know there's no labor is this yeah
that's what that's sexy
they've been it's also feel sexy you
better soul food feel sexy when you
listen time when you're listening to PMC
oh that's a wrap that's a chicken wrap
bye
[Music]